si l'on en croit monsieur alain savary
le ministre l'éducation nationale
l'intention de sa réforme qui en deux
idées démocratisation et meilleure
qualification un peu partout en france
les étudiants de diverses disciplines
porteuses pourtant contre la sélection
il estime qu'il n'y a pas eu de
véritable concertation et redoutent
l'examen de fin de deuxième alors une
première question générale à vous
monsieur jacques bodiot vous êtes le
premier vice président de la conférence
des universités des présidents
d'université et en tant que tel vous
avez donc participé à l'élaboration de
cette réforme alors est ce que vous
comprenez sincèrement la profonde
inquiétude de ces jeunes qui manifestent
actuellement
bien évidemment je vois pas comment on
pourrait ne pas là qu'on peut la
comprendre
ça va faire une réforme c'est toujours
difficile sans provoquer de réaction
je rappelle simplement que la mise en
place du premier cycle en 73 avait
suscité des grèves qui avait duré six
semaines et que la mise en place de
réformes du second site 176 avait
provoqué des grèves qui avaient duré
jusqu'à 11 semaines dans la quasi
totalité des établissements alors que
d'une façon préventive cette fois des
grèves se manifeste dans certaines des
universités françaises et dans certaines
disciplines est certainement
significatif
je crois que ce qui est à observer c'est
que ces mouvements concerne
essentiellement les sciences de l'homme
et les sciences sociales dans les
disciplines technologiques qui constitue
tout de même un enjeu phénoménal pour
notre pays
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons rien vu ce
qui me paraît évident c'est que les
étudiants craignent quant à l'avenir et
on le comprend bien évidemment dans la
conjoncture économique
on se trouve et ils sont prêts
finalement recevoir toutes les
informations on peut leur donner plus ou
moins bien contrôlé à cet égard ayant
été personnellement associé à
l'élaboration de cette loi
j'entends des interprétations qui sont
absolument dénué de tout fondement
notamment et j'espère qu'on y reviendra
sur cette fameuse sélection que je
cherche vainement du moins dans des
conditions différentes de celles qui
existent à l'heure actuelle mais je
pense qu'on reviendra sur ce point à
vous monsieur savoir vous trouvez que
cette réforme n'est pas que des
avantages et vous trouvez que les étions
bien des raisons de manifester je pense
effectivement que les étudiants ont bien
des raisons manifester les avantages
quant à moi je les cherche
je les cherche et puisque nous parlons
simplement de ce point
deux sélections dont monsieur audio
vient de faire allusion à ce problème le
précisément quand on voit la loi il y a
quelque chose d'extrêmement 9
c'est d'une part qu'il peut y avoir une
sélection à la fin du premier cycle
une sélection que je qualifierais avec
d'autres de sauvage puisque c'est dans
les limites des capacités d'accueil des
établissements ce qui est quelque chose
de tout à fait nouveau est que dans ce
cadre là il peut y avoir concours où il
peut y avoir un examen de dossier s'est
inscrit noir sur blanc dans la loi dont
j'ai relu le texte avant de venir sur ce
plateau
absolument pas je crois que là et alain
savary a déjà donné des informations et
des précisions sur le sens d'un texte
qui demande peut être en effet être
rédigé d'une façon plus claire
le concours nous nous sommes battus pour
que les universités aient le droit de
délivrer le meilleur des titres français
qui est le diplôme d'ingénieur on ne
peut pas délivrer un diplôme d'ingénieur
si l'on ne met pas un concours à
l'entrée de la formation conduisant à la
délivrance de ce gr les limitations
revêtant la forme de sélection sur
dossier de faisant référence aux
capacités d'accueil
je suis désolé cela existe lorsque on
non une maîtrise de sciences et
technique quelle que soit la discipline
on limite le nombre des étudiants et on
le fait depuis dix ans lorsque l'on
montre une maîtrise professionnelle une
maîtrise d'informatique appliquée à la
gestion par exemple pour prendre un
domaine pas trop peu éloigné du vôtre on
limite le nombre des étudiants
que dit la loi elle dit que dans
certaines formations les universités
pourront limiter les conditions
d'accueil ce qui signifie qu'elles
pourront continuer à faire ce qu'elles
font actuellement
voilà rigoureusement ce que signifie
cette référence à la sélection et que
les étudiants en droit ne se fasse pas
de souci s'agissant des maîtrise de
droit qui s'appelleront peut être
autrement
ils n'auront pas demain de sélection ils
entreront de droit comme le dit le texte
dans son premier alinéa avec le diplôme
de premier cycle en revanche lorsque
comme aujourd'hui et on peut l'espérer
plus qu'aujourd'hui les disciplines
juridiques monteront
et maîtrise par exemple de fiscalité
appliquée à l'entreprise ou de gestion
du personnel comme aujourd'hui
elles feront une sélection elles le font
aujourd'hui pourquoi serait ce bien
aujourd'hui et mauvais demain je crois
que les paroles de monsieur l'audio ne
suffiront pas à rassurer les étudiants
et tout spécialement les étudiants en
droit puisque je constate à tout le
moins qu'après avoir nié l'existence
d'une sélection sur dossier sur concours
dans la loi il vient de la reconnaître à
l'instant de telle sorte que ce qui
inquiète vivement les étudiants c'est
précisément qu'ils ont le sentiment
qu'on tente de les lanternes et et
qu'après avoir parlé de concertation on
nous sort un texte de loi qui entre nous
soit dit est un véritable gruyère
puisque sur 68 articles et 30 pages ont
réussi néanmoins à renvoyer à 50 décret
donc par définition nous ignorons le
texte on y la spécificité des études
juridiques comme or ni la spécificité de
toutes filières et on organise si vous
avez envie qu'on continue à discuter
donc s'il reste des flous devait être
plutôt contents non comme ça vous allez
pouvoir faire faire entendre vos idées
c'est ce que nous tentons de faire ce
qui est fâcheux c'est que nous soyons
obligés du moins en ce qui concerne les
étudiants de les faire entendre dans la
rue car a priori c'est effectivement pas
le lieu d'un débat démocratique
moi je suis un petit peu étonné parce
que monsieur savary dit qu'il n'y aura
la sélection sera ni générale ni
obligatoire maintenant donc vous à ce
moment là vous êtes pour la sélection il
ya une espèce de revirements parce
qu'autant je me souvienne la gauche
lorsqu'elle était dans l'opposition
encourager quelques étudiants à à crier
contre la sélection donc maintenant
vouloir établi c'est d'une certaine
manière ou tout au moins vous le
maintenez comme la professionnalisation
d'ailleurs on a nié hier et que
maintenant on demande un des grands axes
de la loi il ya une chose qui m'étonne
c'est que beaucoup de ceux qui hier
était pour la sélection et pour la
professionnalisation semble trouver que
la sélection et la professionnalisation
sont aujourd'hui la pire des choses et
je m'interroge laisse pas sur les
raisons de ce revirement
s'agissant de la gauche
eh bien elle est peut-être hier contre
la sélection elle est encore aujourd'hui
contre la sélection
sans vouloir remettre en cause celles
qui existent dans les iut par exemple
celles qui existent d'un définir de
deuxième cycle que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
il est évident que lorsque vous faites
une formation relativement pointues en
escomptant un nombre de débouchés
relativement connu il serait stupide
d'accueillir à l'intérieur cinq fois
plus d'étudiants de la même façon
lorsque vous faites une formation
d'informaticiens avec un nombre de
consoles donné il serait stupide va
accueillir plus d'étudiants que l'on ne
peut en recevoir puisque vous faisiez
référence aux possibilités et vos
capacités d'accueil et bien je ne sais
pas qui a changé mais je n'ai pas le
sentiment que ce soit la gauche- jeu sa
voix vous devriez plutôt content qu'on
prépare des étudiants vers des métiers
où ils vont effectivement trouver un
emploi bon alors premièrement c'est une
affirmation qui me semble quelque peu
gratuites et pour répondre à ce qui
vient d'être dit moi je constate que est
long le on le sait que les conversions
les plus tardives sont souvent les plus
sincères pour ne pas dire les plus
sectaires alors d'une part on nous
affirme aujourd'hui on nous vante les
mérites d'une sélection qui me paraît
mois incontrôlée je fais partie de ceux
qui ont aujourd'hui et qui continue de
dire qu'il faut avoir le courage
d'affirmer que tout système
d'enseignement est par définition
sélectif mais le problème est de savoir
ce qu'il convient de mettre derrière ce
vocable de sélection s'agit-il d'une
sélection quantitative comme c'est le
cas dans le projet de loi savary
alors là nous y sommes fondamentalement
hostile ou s'agit-il d'une sélection
qualitative alors il ne suffit pas de
bonnes paroles et de dénégation
nous nous sommes des juristes mes
étudiants sont des juristes et nous leur
avons appris un certain nombre de choses
nous lisons le texte et nous constatons
d'une part qu'il y as élections d'autre
part qu' on les oriente vers un premier
cycle et qui finalement n'a pas de
raison d'être un premier cycle
indifférenciée un premier cycle général
pour toutes les disciplines
ce qui veut donc dire de deux choses
l'une ou bien les études juridiques vont
être dévalorisé si elle reste dans la
même enveloppe temporel ou bien au
contraire il conviendra d'allonger les
formations puisque on ne fera plus dans
le premier cycle
ce que nous faisons à l'heure actuelle
vous êtes satisfait de la situation
actuelle des études juridiques notamment
il n'est pas en ce qui nous concerne
question de prôné le statu quo nous
disons simplement que dans la loi il ya
un certain nombre de
sûrs qu'ils sont particulièrement
néfastes nous parlons pour l'instant de
celle des mesures qui sensibilise le
plus les étudiants
il y en a un certain nombre d'autres qui
sensibilise les enseignants et dans
lesquelles nous voyons une véritable
tentative de mise au pas l'université
alors je sais bien que c'est un
mouvement politique c'est ça je ne sais
pas si elle est politique au sens
partisan du terme et en intégrant tout
cas elle est politique par définition un
texte de loi et politique on lançait n'y
dans nos facultés dans nos universités
nous le savons mais monsieur vous dit
vous qui avez participé à ses traits à
l'élaboration de cette réforme vous êtes
un militaire vous êtes en train de
mettre au pas les universités c'est ça
oui je crois que cette loi est
profondément politique ou sens noble du
terme car il est politique
en effet de vouloir mettre un terme à
l'abominable sélection par l'échec que
nous connaissons à l'heure actuelle 60 %
les étudiants qui entrent en premier si
tu n'en sortent pas et ce que l'on veut
par l'orientation dont on préfère en
parler dans le corps de la loi quand
comme en 68 dans le titre et le sera le
meilleur semble ça c'est politique en
effet pratiquer une sélection oui une
sélection positive c'est-à-dire faire en
sorte que la sélection s'opère par le
succès et non pas par l'échec
ça c'est politique c'est certain mais on
parlait à l'instant
et là ce sont de pure et simple
extrapolation de textes d'application
d'une loi qui n'est pas encore votée
alors comment pourrait on connaître les
textes d'application d'une loi qui n'est
pas encore votée et dans certains
souhaitent d'ailleurs qu'elle ne le soit
pas alors ils attaquent des textes qui
par définition ne peuvent pas exister
tant que la loi n'est pas votée
on nous dit qu'on va ruiner la
spécificité des uns ou des autres
genevois fera absolument pas en quoi je
ne vois pas pourquoi vous aurez encore
des premiers cycles de d'études
juridiques parce que je ne pense pas que
l'on découvre de meilleurs moyens de
former des juristes que de leur
enseigner le droit et je pense que cette
idée simple a effleuré
les la pensée de ceux qui ont beaucoup
consulté d'ailleurs pour élaborer ce
texte
dernière question que les juristes
certes il un professeur de droit non je
patine une grève des examens vous en
êtes de ces de ses professeurs
personnellement je ne suis pas de ces
professeurs puisque personnellement
j'estime que au regard des étudiants la
grève des examens est un mouvement
suicidaire
en revanche je compte au nombre des
enseignants et des étudiants qui sont
fondamentalement hostile à ce projet on
nous abreuve de bonnes paroles rappées
nous fait croire souhaité que ce projet
cette grève s'arrête et bien dans un
premier temps et de ce point de vue
notre objectif et jédir extrêmement
modestes nous souhaitons le report de la
discussion à la session d'automne afin
qu'enfin une véritable concertation
puisse ouvrir qu'on puisse amender la
loi sur le projet de loi pardon sur
celle de ces dispositions qui sont les
plus critiquables et je dirais que nous
n'avons que l'embarras du choix et je
regrette pour ma part que on a eu une
discussion qui soit par trop générale
qu'on n'ait pas abordé un petit peu le
contenu de ce texte
oui un certain nombre de dispositions ou
à l'évidence parce que en dehors des
bonnes paroles et j'allais dire sous la
paille des mots il faut rechercher le
grain des choses et bien il y à un
certain nombre de dispositions qui sont
tout simplement néfastes pour
l'université française avec un e
majuscule peut-être l'occasion de vous
prouver mais ce qu'il ya une possibilité
de négociation est ce que vous avez
moyen d'arrêter cette grain ajouté
lorsque le ministre lui-même explique ce
que veulent dire les mots ce sont des
bonnes paroles
alors lorsque l'on me donne des
interprétations erronées qui ne sont pas
conformes aux intentions du gouvernement
d'une part et très bientôt du
législateur je répondrai mois que aux
bonnes paroles on répond par des procès
d'intention vous êtes réalisateur il me
paraît évident que lorsque l'on a
conduit pendant 18 mois la concertation
qui a été conduite
on est toujours prêts à la discussion
mais de grâce respectons le
fonctionnement des institutions
républicaines l'heure le gouvernement a
adopté ce projet ce projet devant le
parlement
c'est au parlement à recevoir les
doléances c'est au parlement
à voter éventuellement les amendements
qui apporteront les apaisements
nécessaires quant à l'interprétation à
donner à ce texte car je n'ose pas
penser que l'on critique ce texte pour
d'autres raisons que ce qui est dans ce
texte ce serait là un sujet qui ne me
concernerait plus merci beaucoup
maintenant voyons là